to my dying day will stand by every word
of my testimony amber heard not backing
down from her accusations of abuse at
the hands of johnny depp this was the
most humiliating and horrible thing i've
ever been through her other post-trial
revelations
inside brittany and sam's new love nest
down the street from k-fed the slab from
tyler perry's perspective
when we walked over to him he was
devastated he couldn't believe what
happened he couldn't believe he did it
et's the download starts right now
[Music]
we begin with amber hurd doubling down
on that bombshell testimony she gave in
court against johnny depp in her first
sit down since the trial she tells
today's savannah guthrie she made
mistakes in her marriage but always told
the truth about being the victim of
domestic violence to my dying day will
stand by every word of my testimony this
was the most humiliating and horrible
thing i've ever been through in the
closing arguments the depth lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers i'm the
performer
the depth team argued that you
were the abuser that you instigated
physical violence did you
i never had to instigate it i responded
to it and it doesn't end there heard was
grilled over the evidence i am looking
at a transcript that says he says you
start physical fights and you say i did
start a physical fight i can't promise
you i won't get physical again
i mean this is in black and white when
your life is at risk you take the blame
for things that you shouldn't take the
blame for i
did do and say horrible
regrettable things throughout my
relationship
i behaved in horrible
almost unrecognizable to myself ways
there's so much i have so much regret
the truth is the word yes and that was
the issue and that's all i spoke
and i spoke it to power and i paid the
price that price more than 10 million
dollars owed to death after a jury found
she defamed him in a 2018 op-ed johnny
depp did not bring this case in order to
get damages but instead just to clear
his name
but at the same time if amber heard and
her team continue to double down on the
defamatory statements
johnny depp may not be so sympathetic in
regards to a seeking damages and b going
after amber heard again for defamation
a source told et this week that hurd has
plans for a comeback over the next year
her team is now shutting down rumors
that she's been officially cut from
aquaman two telling e.t they're
inaccurate and sensitive and slightly
insane this after more than four and a
half million people signed this
change.org petition to have her removed
from the film now during the trial she
testified that her role was
significantly cut because of her
personal drama even after her co-star
jason momoa allegedly fought for her to
return to the franchise i kind of showed
up to work months early and
stayed really late
to fight to keep the job i had to fight
really hard to keep my career i got
cancelled from jobs fought to keep my
job and
in a movie opportu the biggest movie
opportunity i had to date which was what
uh it was justice league later became
aquaman
now on to jlo who's also not holding
back her feelings about co-headlining
the 2020 super bowl with shakira this is
the worst idea in the world to have two
people do the super bowl
[Music]
while many took that as a diva dig
against shakira in jayla's new netflix
dock halftime out today she explains the
concern was about splitting their short
window of time on stage they said 12
minutes if it was going to be a double
headliner they should have given us 20
minutes it was an insult to say you
needed
two latinas
to do the job that one artist
historically has done
a behind the scenes secret about
daughter emma's super bowl cameo
[Music]
j-lo first envisioned bruce springsteen
taking the stage and had a tough time
getting shakira on board she's like i
wasn't born in the usc but everybody
loves to sing that song fiance ben
affleck is also featured in the doc
talking about the racism jennifer faced
during her rise to fame i said to her
once
doesn't this bother you
and she said i'm latina i'm a woman
i i expected this
yeah i love seeing it ben featured in
the doc as well it's a beautiful moment
meanwhile the bts army is in a frenzy
after the super group announced after
nine years they're taking a break
they dropped this bomb as part of an
hour-long video and dinner party they
hold each year to celebrate their
anniversary as a band but in a statement
to et their rep makes it clear this
isn't a hiatus the band is just taking
time to explore some solo projects
including an album from jungkook and
solo releases from suga and j-hope and
the video v shared his hopes for an
eventual reunion
do you have a message you want to wave
to the bts army army stay tuned
stay tuned you heard him all right first
comes love then comes marriage then
comes a 12 million dollar home if you're
lucky
britney spears and husband samus gary
have found their new love note a source
tells e.t the newlyweds purchased an
11.8 million dollar estate that sits on
1.6 acres in calabasas california but
get this the house is apparently in the
same community as brit's ex kevin
federline now our source says kevin was
surprised that in all of california all
the homes for sale and all of the gated
communities brittany and sam decided to
choose the same one that he's in still
the source added as long as their move
doesn't invite paparazzi and a
free-for-all more power
now according to the property listing
the house is a sprawling singing
single-story estate with seven bedrooms
nine bathrooms a heated pool home gym
movie theater wine cellar and separate
maids quarters
[Music]
last week britain sam said i do at her
thousand oaks california home that is
also where the singer's first husband
jason alexander was arrested after he
crashed the wedding and now a judge has
granted britney a three-year protective
order against her ex jason who pleaded
not guilty to the charges against him
including felony stalking must stay at
least 100 yards away from brittany and
sam
now on to justin bieber who is leaning
on faith through his ramsey hunt
syndrome diagnosis which he says has led
to facial paralysis and difficulty
eating
as you can see this eye is not blinking
i can't smile on this side of my face
his perspective has given me peace
during this horrific storm that i'm
facing he shares in a new update on
instagram i know this storm will pass
but in the meantime jesus is with me
meanwhile bruce willis's wife emma is
praising her hubby for his fearlessness
amid his aphasia diagnosis she shares
throwback footage from 1987
of bruce with the temptations
[Applause]
the caption reads what kind of next
level confidence does it take to sing
lead with the temptations this guy has
always been led by his passion and has
never let naysayers stop him from well
anyway
now to tyler perry three months after
that infamous oscar slap he's reliving
those tense moments while with gayle
king at the tribeca film festival you
might remember tyler was seen talking to
will immediately after he hit chris rock
it was wrong in no uncertain terms and i
made sure i said that to will when we
walked over to him he was devastated he
couldn't believe what happened and to
get all the way
to this moment of winning the oscar that
was the one of the crowning moments of
his career that he wanted so desperately
were you comforting him there's a
difference between comforting and
de-escalating yeah and being friends
with both of them has been very
difficult
so tyler was there to talk about his
incredible directing career which
actually now includes another big honor
he was given the impact award by whoopi
goldberg at the apollo theater's spring
gala last night in harlem and he gave
e.t an update on their joint project
sister act three i'm letting everybody
who the bladder the writers and the
director and whoopee they all figured
out i'm just along for the ride speaking
of trilogies julie andrews might just be
crushing any dreams of queen clarisse
rinaldi returning to the big screen for
another princess diaries movie i might
just be
a little too old a granny for it i don't
know it depends what the story is and if
they can come up with something that
would be wonderful but if not there'll
be other things though no plans are in
place for a princess diaries 3 andrews
tells et she thinks princess mia herself
and hathaway would be game
shut
up
i beg your pardon
and a source tells e.t today that lady
gaga is in very early talks to play
harley quinn opposite joaquin phoenix in
the joker sequel which the hollywood
reporter says will actually be a musical
our source says there's no official
offer on the table for gaga just yet and
joaquin isn't locked in either but last
week director todd phillips shared the
title for the movie on instagram with a
photo of the joker himself reading the
script joaquin won an oscar for the role
back in 2020. meanwhile bj novak is
gunning for success on the big screen
too we were with him at the tribeca film
festival in new york this week when he
reunited with his old boss ashton
kutcher
it was kind of this amazing full circle
moment right like i i i cast him on
punks when he was first getting going
and
i was directing him
he gave me my first on camera so if it
weren't for him i wouldn't be starring
in this
bj and ashton starr alongside issa ray
in vengeance hitting theaters july 29th
it's a comedy thriller about a
journalist investigating a mysterious
death the movie is bj's directorial
debut so his the office co-star mindy
kaling came out to support i can't
believe that every single year that goes
by the office is a bigger and bigger
deal we were never this popular when we
were actually on television ashton's
wife mila was recently named one of
time's 100 most influential people
thanks to her efforts to help raise
relief for ukraine she might be of 100
for time but she's up number one for me
issa wrapped insecure at the end of last
year but she still keeps in touch with
the cast including jay ellis who stars
as payback in top gun maverick i went to
the movies for the first time in three
years because of him and i was just so
proud to see him up there it was a good
movie
i left like damn i'm glad i saw that
now to jay's co-star miles teller the
thirst y'all is real since top gun
maverick premiered thanks in part to
these oiled abs i'm reading it slow for
your viewing pleasure
and the person you'd least expect is
feeding all this fan friends there
teller talk
people are freaking out about that they
say you're starting a revolution with
this are you even aware of it are you
just out there having a good time
not real i mean i a little bit just
because i don't have you know uh
instagram or tick tock or anything but i
know my i know my wife i'll just see her
on her phone and then she'll start
cracking up and so then she shares with
me um you know what's going on
get this his better half has posted at
least half a dozen videos of miles being
all sorts of sexy from shaking his buns
to going shirtless with his bros and of
course those clips of him playing
rooster
[Music]
we thank you mrs teller
miles flies high in maverick but takes a
walk on the dark side as a convict in
the sci-fi thriller spider-head
streaming on netflix this friday his
co-star is another addie chris
he's somebody that i was really excited
to work with you know everybody who
meets chris works with chris they we
pretty much all have the same things to
say about him just he's a he's an
incredible
person and he's he's a wonderful scene
partner he's just a great guy man he's
he's really wonderful
moving on to wendy williams whose big
news tops today's talk show circuit a
spokesperson for the show tells e.t the
final episode of her daytime show will
air this friday after 13 years in
syndication and will include a wendy
tribute video she hasn't been seen on
her own show all season while dealing
with health and financial issues a
series of guest hosts have been filling
in including sherry shepherd who will be
taking over the time slot this fall
starting in september i am debuting my
own talk show
and about four years ago i started
telling god i said lord i want a talk
show
and when god says it's so
it will be
thank you
he's not in tears but post malone is
also celebrating new beginnings he let
this slip to howard stern this week that
he's officially a girl dad i went and i
kissed my baby girl
and then i went
uh and played some when baby girl that
you're referring to your girlfriend or
you have a baby
no that's my daughter oh you have a
daughter
yes sir that's been on the qt though we
didn't know you had a daughter right you
keep all that quiet
yeah i don't i want to let her make her
own decisions amazing well he also
admitted to howard stern his favorite
place to write is on the toilet
no one wants to come talk to you while
you're taking it
right
right
no one wants to come and talk to no one
i don't care who it is but does your
girlfriend ever say to you is she your
girlfriend or your wife at this point
this is my she's my fancy oh oh do you
hear that i heard it
guys we didn't know he was engaged
either well listen another artist halsey
told jimmy fallon last night who she'd
pick to play her in a movie this is you
as
millie bobby brown
millie bobby brown should play you yeah
i mean yeah millie would be great but i
don't really think i'm famous enough to
cast millie you'll do it though right no
millie millie would be so great millie i
mean it's kind of uncanny how much we
look alike it's like oh no we actually
just look like sisters
i mean the proof is in the pudding y'all
can you see the resemblance i see it
it's awesome i love it all right
speaking of acting faith hill confessed
to kelly clarkson which movie almost
derailed her hollywood career i did
stepford wives and um with an amazing
cast amazing amazing cast it wasn't the
best experience so i said i will never
ever ever ever do another
anything like that
faith says that all changed after she
read the script for the yellowstone
spin-off 1883 from of course showrunner
taylor sheridan but she and husband tim
mcgraw told us last month they don't
plan on reprising their roles
i think
we'd like margaret and james to sort of
live in that atmosphere that they
created for 1883. if taylor sheridan
comes calling would you would you say
yes depends on the show i'd be happy
happy to read one if he brought it our
way
praise be we're getting a first look at
handmaid's tale season 5 and if you're
not caught up i'm telling you right now
spoiler alert hulu released this image
of elizabeth moss as june osborne
looking angry and determined as ever as
she prepares to face the consequences of
killing commander waterford while
struggling to redefine herself and
here's yvonne strawski as serena joy
waterford looking smug while dressed in
morning clothes likely at her husband's
funeral now over the last year ichi has
talked with the stars of the show who've
been tight-lipped about the new season
premiering september 14th what can you
tell us about where we're going cause
season five i can tell you i'm in it i
know i'm gonna be there anything you can
tease get out of here she's okay i tried
y'all i really tried i all i mean it's
just it's gonna be wild there's a lot of
stuff going on i i was surprised i was
like were you
on to another show that keeps us on the
edge of our seats
you on netflix only et's rachel smith
talk to star penn badgley about what's
next for our favorite stalker i will
find
you one would think
that things are going to pick up in
season four
on puppy ah
what
but not the case y'all are in london
what gives um
look to be real it's cheaper
i can't imagine having to let go of joe
and then go home to your lovely wife and
kids you know it's like oh let me play
with the toddler now yeah right i don't
i mean yes i have a little bit of fake
blood in my fingernails sorry let me
just i'm like an action star you can
trust me with this secret love if it's
up then
cardi b's really enjoying watching some
joe as well
might we see cardi pop up she did pitch
to netflix saying hey i could be in
paris fashion week i mean you know carly
and i still haven't even met in person
we were right we were trying to make
something happen can let e.t arrange
this
penn's a busy guy he just finished
shooting episode four of you and he's
co-hosting a podcast podcrush which has
been reliving the awkward and sweet
moments of middle school the ironic
thing he actually dropped out of school
and traded it for hollywood your first
credit is boy number one on will and
grace in 1999.
i was 12. i know that was insane so you
are living this middle school experience
on television yeah how did that work out
for you i should talk to my therapist
there's something about like bringing
these stories to life how painful that
time is and what are the conditions you
could create that would make that less
painful and more powerful
new episodes drop tuesdays on stitcher
and in each one penn reads an adolescent
story submitted by a listener celeb
guests like drew barrymore amy schumer
and penn's gossip girl co-star lady
meester stopped by too and it was it was
really nice after all this time to just
be
more relaxed and at ease with ourselves
and and reflect on a time when we
weren't
well you know what the nostalgia
continues because we are going on to
another cast reunion et catches up with
the stars of martin 30 years after the
show's premiere this is amazing just
feels like we're about to go back to
work again
and look who is all grown up jay-z
spotted courtside with his not so many
me go inside their daddy daughter date
when etsa downloads returns
[Music]
now to a tv reunion that's got us
stepping back 30 years the cast of
martin et's michelle turner sat down
with the whole comedy crew
i feel like i've come home
you know
this makes my heart so happy god damn
gina when you walked on the set first
thought wow this is amazing it just
feels like we about to go back to work
again the b-e-t plus special martin the
reunion streams thursday and comes 30
years after the groundbreaking comedy
first premiered in 1992. you go girl
when you first started this show did you
think like damn we're going to change
the face of television oh i was just
trying to make the show a success yeah
i want to know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so martin what was yours
forever day day
my top two i would say is shenanigan
jerome yeah but behind the scenes things
weren't always so smooth
in 1997 tisha filed a lawsuit accusing
martin of sexual harassment which he
denied the suit was eventually settled
out of court they have since made peace
there was friction between the two of
you if i'm telling you me and martin
gonna walk out hand in hand if we start
talking about anything
right
it's all love right
not bad
you ain't slapping me oh oh wait a
minute okay well yeah
we're in the age of reboots redos
whatever could we is there any way we
could possibly like keep it going for a
new generation i tell people all the
time
martin will never
be the same without tommy
that would be their beloved castmate
tommy ford who suddenly passed away from
an abdominal aneurysm in 2016. what we
had it was like catching lightning in
the bottle
[Music]
305
that's your first look at issa rey's new
hbo max series rap ish premiering july
21st it's her first project for the
streamer since landing her deal last
year reportedly worth 40 million dollars
over five years we're in the middle of a
bad [ __ ] renaissance issa told et in
april that the series is loosely based
on the city girls young miami and jt who
are esa's co-executive producers
is so exciting to have them
really consult and give us their input
is invaluable to the authenticity of the
show
and it's really inspired by kind of this
moment that we're having
in uh in rap music with so many female
um stars coming up and shining like i
don't think that we've ever had this
many have the spotlight at once
someone else who's having her moment in
the spotlight blew ivy carter she was
looking so shy and so grown up when the
camera caught her sitting courtside with
dad jay-z at game five of the nba finals
back with us in the bay and here at
chase center tonight
24 time grammy award winner
the one and only jay-z
ah ten-year-old blue the spitting image
of mom beyonce by the way in a black
leather jacket in gold hoop earrings
stole the show y'all when she told her
dad to watch the hair did you catch that
as he leaned in for a kiss on the cheek
now sources tell e.t she was embarrassed
if you couldn't tell by the jumbotron
cameo but that quickly turned to
excitement as she got up close and
personal with this nba superstar
yeah
i feel like it probably takes a lot to
leave blue starstruck but steph curry
may have done the trick i love it all
right that does it for us today make
sure to join us right here tomorrow for
a new episode of the download everyone
[Music]